Хорошо, я начну новую снимку, Оскар, сделай?
Хорошо.
Хорошо, сниму, сниму.
Это шаг номер пять.
Оскар, можете заменить себя в Discord?
Да.
Следующий шаг — революционная революция.
Нужно создать автотрансляцию.
Это здесь?
Да, языка, различная интерфейс, русский язык.
Можно ли выключить сеть и выключить язык?
Хорошо.
Нужно создать автотрансляцию.
Я вижу слово, в котором написано что обнаружено несколько языков.
Сейчас я слышу Оскара.
Я также вижу перевод.
Сейчас я вижу Оскара, он говорит, я вижу, что переводится в слова с английского на русский и переводит на телесный язык.
Кажется работает, он меня теперь слышит.
Потому что я говорю на русском.
И все похоже правильно переводят.
Да, я вижу.
Некоторые.
Да.
У меня смеет на другой, не уверен.
Какой язык, но...
Вверху слева указан язык, с которого переводят.
У меня описано как русский, у меня описано как английский.
В переводе всплываются случайные фразы и тексты окна в изуме.
Да.
А, ну, немножко никакая.
Спасибо.
Я согласен.
Субтитры сделал DimaTorzok